Immigration law,
the opening of
rights to statues of officials to foreigners.
With 3 days to go before a bill arrives in the Senate
immigration and integration,
Hill talk,
sense of public service,
offers Friday 03/11deux-mille-vingt-trois
to open the status of civil servant to foreigners
non-European.
While the public service faces 1
major crisis of attractiveness,
they themselves of skills
exclude 1 part of the population.
More than 4,000,000 civil servant jobs
cannot be occupied
by non-European foreigners.
The collective believes that this measure could
be part of the immigration bill
that needs to be debated
from Monday 06/11deux-mille-vingt-trois in Cameroon.
120 socialist senators
have filed 1
amendment that asks the government to draft
1 report on
access conditions
to the public service of foreigners
non-European.
Republicans are particularly opposed to the article
3 which provides for
regularize the
undocumented workers in the trades
who are struggling the most to recruit.
According to the latest available figures,
the public service has approximately
3,8000,000 civil servants,
three hundred and ten
1000 military and 1,2000,000 contractual.